[Music]
did you know that only two and five
kiwis feel that they're well prepared
for a disaster
weather events in our district have been
getting more frequent and more severe
but many of us are still in the dark
about how to prepare and what to do
during an event
in this video we'll talk about what to
do when a weather warning is issued and
also give you some tips and tricks as to
how to prepare for wild weather
weather warnings are issued by the Met
service and they tell us what to expect
during an extreme weather event the
camps alerts residents of relevant
warnings via our website and social
media we then provide updates on
anything that's relevant to our local
area
there are some simple steps you can take
to prepare your whanau and your home for
extreme weather as our climate changes
we expect to see average temperatures
increase
the warmer atmosphere will hold more
moisture so rainfall is predicted to
increase and we will see more frequent
heavy rainfall events
it's best to prepare before the rain
sits in
make sure you clean out gutters or
debris trim your trees to make sure
they're not encroaching on your driveway
in case Emergency Services Vehicles need
to get through if your property is prone
to flooding make sure you have sandbags
ready or alternatively stock up on some
tub pollens and some empty sacks that
you can fill
and if you need to store precious
materials out in your sheds or your
garages store them up high
for more detailed information and to put
together a plan for your whanau visit
getready.govt.nz if there's a potential
risk to life or an imminent threat of
flood waters entering your home call 111
immediately if it's flooded forget it
the less urgent issues with drainage in
your street or roads overflowing or for
any other issues please find the council
service center during periods of extreme
weather we triage our calls and attend
to the most urgent ones first
council's civil defense Response Team
visit affected properties and help where
needed if you encounter flood water
treat it as if it's contaminated don't
plan it and wash your hands thoroughly
afterwards if you do come into contact
we also deploy sucker tracks and pumps
and flood prone areas to help protect
property as much as we can Surface
flooding on roads and roadsides is
common in heavy rain events especially
on our rural roads across the district
we have more than 1500 kilometers of
Roads so during a major weather event we
make sure to focus on our busiest
arterial roads first
our roading team constantly check the
network for any issues and put signage
in place where it's most needed
roads and Fords will be closed where
necessary
as a driver you can do a lot to help
always drive to the conditions and
assume flood water is deeper than it
looks
by just on cones and science to warn you
in major weather events make sure you
drive to the conditions there may be
potholes hazardous debris or unstable
Road surfaces beneath the water
if you must enter flood water Drive
slowly so you do not cause waves which
can damage neighboring properties
changed rapidly during heavy rainfall
and there's always the chance that
you're the first motorist to encounter a
hazard if you are concerned about
driving during Heavy Rain or through
flood water just don't
Council has roving crews out in the
event of a major weather event
but we can't be everywhere at all times
so please let us know if you see
something on the roads if the event
escalates Vermeer could declare a state
of emergency Council will set up an
Emergency Operations Center where key
staff civil defense and Emergency
Services will work together and share
information and strategies the best way
to stay up to date in your area is to
check council's Facebook page and
website
WE Post regular updates with the latest
information from inside the Emergency
Operations Center evacuations may be
ordered for residents or properties and
areas where a river is about to breach
its banks households affected will be
contacted and if possible emergency
response staff will assist them to
evacuate
we ask people to stay with friends or
family outside of the affected area in
the first instance
if that's not possible temporary
accommodation will be provided when the
situation improves civil defense will
issue an all-clear message for people to
return home and if possible emergency
response staff can assist them to do
that in a single weather event Council
usually receives around a thousand calls
that require action or further
investigation there are multiple or
close weather events this can create a
backlog Council will triage the service
calls and respond to the most urgent
ones first people can normally expect a
response from Council staff within a
couple of weeks however sometimes it can
take months to work through that volume
of requests where a decision is made to
carry out remedial or mitigation works
this will either be carried out in that
same Financial year or budgeted in the
council's annual plan or long-term plan
for carrying out in future years
please use the council website to keep
yourself updated on progress and
projects
[Music]
foreign